Now I want to dig in to a subtle way in which
CNN manufactured consent against Bernie Sanders
during Tuesday night's debate with the graphics
that were on the screen. But before I do this,
I want to be really clear here. I'm doing
this as a media analysis story. It's a political
analysis story. You all know I have not been
on the, everyone hates Bernie bandwagon. I've
actually been criticized because I haven't
supported Bernie enough. I haven't endorsed
Bernie, whatever, when the media has blacked
out. Bernie, I've said it when the conspiracy
theories have gone too far. I've pointed out
this is going too far. We also have already
talked about how the Tuesday debate was the
sickening climax of the story about Bernie
Sanders supposedly telling Elizabeth Warren
in 2018 that a woman couldn't win the presidency,
which absent any context is essentially a
meaningless assertion.
So this story is not about any of that stuff.
Okay? Put all of that aside. This is a story
about how CNN used onscreen graphics to subtly
push certain narratives. So remember this
was a democratic debate. CNN as the moderator
of the debate was supposed to be the unbiased
arbiter allowing the candidates to outline
their policies, to talk to each other about
how they view other candidates policies as
either flawed or not. Good enough for suboptimal.
The candidates were supposed to do that. Check
out how CNN inserted an anti Bernie narrative
into the presentation. This is Fox news type
stuff. To be clear, onscreen graphic says,
Warren supports a new trade deal with Mexico
and Canada. Why is Sanders opposition to it
wrong? Well, who is right and wrong as part
of the debate, right? The question presumes
as it is written on screen that Bernie is
wrong and Warren is right to support it.
This is a push framing in the debate. Next
example, quote Sanders proposals would double
federal spending over a decade. How will he
avoid bankrupting the country? This one's
toxic for a few reasons. It assumes that it
would bankrupt the country, which ignores
many facts, including that the country can
just print more money to avoid bankruptcy.
It can have other unintended consequences.
Sure, but the foregone conclusion of bankruptcy
is a joke. Not to mention that it ignores
that. Every candidate on that stage refuse
to say they would pull all troops from the
middle East. That costs a ton of money. No
one asks what that is going to cost us and
if we can afford it. Remember Elizabeth Warren
saying she would pull all combat troops that's
playing coy with peacekeeping troops. Bernie
listed other things that he would prefer troops
do, but also said he's not pulling them because
none of them are going to pull all the troops
from the middle East.
Uh, okay. Crazy to put this up on the screen.
Next talking point on the screen. Does Sanders
owe voters an explanation of how much his
healthcare plan will cost them in the country?
So with this one, there's a lot going on.
Every candidate should justify how much their
ideas will cost and where the money will come
from. That never is asked of candidates when
it's about war or military deployment. And
Bernie has outlined the cost for his plan.
You can say that he's wrong about what it
will cost. You can say it's not worth the
expenditure. You can debate that. But again,
pretending that he's not addressed the cost
as the basis for the topic is an absolute
and total joke. Last one here. What did Warren
think when Sanders talked to her about whether
a woman could win the election? Again, Bernie
denied that.
They talked about this. CNN asked Bernie,
he said, Oh, I didn't say that, and then they
put this up and say to Warren, how did you
feel when Bernie said you couldn't win? Part
of the debate is whether it was said and CNN
again took a side when they take the Warren
position as a foregone conclusion. There was
one other one I I meant to put up on the screen
and couldn't find, which was after Bernie
and Warren weighed in about that issue. They
went to other candidates like Amy Klobuchar
and the graphic on screen said something like,
what do you think about candidates who say
a woman can't be president? And it's like,
again, we haven't established that it was
said. The one person accused of saying it
denied it two minutes prior and it's still
how CNN handles the onscreen graphics. This
is another way in which the entire thing was
completely biased. CNN should be ashamed of
itself, period. I don't know that they are
capable of feeling shame much like our president
of the United States.